i'm elizabeth thompson with cbc news
with us today we have dr teresa tam and
dr howard new from the public health
agency of canada who will give us their
weekly briefing on covet 19.
owner doctor we have dr terry
19 disease activity indicators including
weekly case counts have been declining
for the past few weeks
and many of the areas of the country
appear to be at or past the peak of
their current wave activity however some
regional variability in disease and
severity trends is being observed
including in wastewater signals and
hospitalization numbers
similar to previous waves lagging civic
severity indicators are slower to
decline but are expected to stabilize
and decline following infection rates
as the sarco v2 virus continues to
circulate worldwide we must prepare for
renewed activity
and potential new variants of the virus
in the months ahead
in particular as part of reading
ourselves for the fall with more people
returning to in-person work and children
going back to work
getting vaccinations up to date is a top
priority
this applies for covert 19 as well as
for other vaccine preventable diseases
given outbreaks and circulation of
measles polio and meningococcal disease
in other countries
in the almost two years since covert 19
vaccines first became available
health canada the public health agency
of canada and the national advisory
committee on immunization have been
closely monitoring vaccine safety
with more than 87 million doses
administered in canada and billions
worldwide covert 19 vaccines have been
shown to have very good safety profiles
evidence continues to demonstrate that
the benefits of covert 19 vaccines
outweigh any risks across all age groups
vaccine effectiveness data show that
cover 19 vaccines provide strong
protection against the most severe
outcomes of the disease including
reducing the risk of hospitalization and
death due to covert 19.
although protection from vaccines and
from previous infection decreases over
time particularly against omicron
variants we know that covet 19 booster
dose
or doses are effective in activating our
immune response to improve protection
against severe outcomes up to 90 percent
today health canada authorized the 10
microgram pfizer biontech
commonarti covet 19 vaccine for use as a
booster dose in children aged 5 to 11
years
and nasi released the national guidance
for its use in canada
this booster dose provides a great
option to restore protection for this
age group especially for those who are
at high risk of severe illness
specifically
nasi recommends that children 5 to 11
years of age who have an underlying
medical condition that places them at
high risk of severe illness due to
covert 19 including children who are
immunocompromised should should be
offered a first boosted dose of the 10
microgram pfizer biontech common arty
covert 19 vaccine at least six months
after completion of a primary series
for all other children in this age group
nasi recommends the 10 microgram
commonality vaccine may be offered as a
first booster at least six months after
completion of a primary series in the
context of heightened epidemiological
risk
although there remains much to be
learned about co post covit19 condition
also known as pcc are long covered
several studies have now shown that
covet 19 vaccination reduces the risk of
developing pcc if a person who is
vaccinated with two or more doses later
becomes infected
ongoing research will help strengthen
the evidence on this important issue
covert 19 prevention strategies
including maintaining up-to-date
vaccination remains the foundation of
our protection individually and
collectively
while less than half of 5 to 11 year
olds have completed their primary series
of vaccines
nasi continues to strongly recommend a
primary series with an authorized mrna
covenanting vaccine as a top priority
although the timing and severity of
future waves is uncertain
nasty recommends a full boost dose
should be offered to eligible people at
increased risk of severe covenanting
illness and may be offered to all other
eligible people regardless of the number
of booster doses previously received
many of the good personal protective
habits we have honed over more than two
years of managing covert 19 can also
reduce your risk of getting infected and
spreading other diseases including
monkey parks and influenza
keeping up with hand washing wearing
masks in poorly ventilated spaces and
staying home if you have symptoms
as we make plans for the fall it is good
time to stock up on good quality face
masks and rapid tests as well as to book
an appointment to check indoor
ventilation or hvac systems to optimize
clean air flow
for our remaining vigilant for cover 19
we are also closely monitoring the
monkey park situation in canada and
internationally
as of august the 19th a total of 1168
confirmed cases of monkey parks
including 30
hospitalizations have been reported
nationally with new brunswick reporting
its first confirmed case this
week nationally there has been a slowing
trend in the increase in new cases
reported in recent weeks
over the 99 over 99
of reported cases are male and the
median age was 36 years
among confirmed cases for whom
additional information is available the
majority reported intimate sexual
contact with other men
to date
the public health agency of canada has
distributed over 105 000 doses of
invermune vaccine to provinces and
territories
with over 59 000 people vaccinated with
at least one dose as of august the 14th
at this time to lower the overall risk
of getting infected and spreading the
monkey pox virus
the public health agency of canada
recommends practicing safer sex having
fewer sexual partners particularly
anonymous partners even when they don't
have symptoms can also reduce your risk
of getting infected thank you merci
migration
and many
is
diseases
is
from vaccines
foreign
protection for this age group
especially for those who are
high-risk severe illness
specifically
recommends the following
children
to children five to 11 years of age who
have an underlying medical condition
that places them at high risk of severe
illness due to corvid 19
including children who are
immunocompromised should be offered at
first booster dose of the 10
paiser bionte combernaticovid19 vaccine
at least six months after completion of
a primary series
for all other children in this age group
nasi recommends that the 10 microgram
commonality vaccine may be offered as a
first booster at least six months after
completion of a primary series in the
context of heightened epidemiological
risks
although there remains much to be
learned about postcovid19 condition also
known as pcc or
long covet
several studies have now shown that
kovid19 vaccination reduces the risk of
developing pcc if a person who's
vaccinated with two or more doses later
becomes infected
ongoing research will also help
strengthen the evidence on this
important issue
19 prevention strategies including
maintaining up-to-date vaccination
remain the foundation of our protection
individually and collectively
while less than half of 5 to 11
eleven-year-olds have completed their
primary series of covet 19 vaccines
nasi continues to strongly recommend a
primary series with an authorized mrna
covet 19 vaccine as a top priority
although the timing and severity of
future waves
of a future wave is uncertain nasi
recommends
that a fall booster dose should be
offered
to eligible people at increased risk of
severe covet 19 illness
and may be offered to all other eligible
people regardless of the number of
booster doses previously received
any of the good personal protective
habits we have honed over more than two
years of managing covid19
can also reduce your risk of getting
infected
and spreading other diseases
including monkey pox and influenza
keep up with hand washing wearing masks
in poorly ventilated places and staying
home if you have symptoms
as we make plans for the fall it is a
good time to stock up on good quality
face masks and rapid tests as well as to
book an appointment to check indoor
ventilation or hvac systems to optimize
clean airflow
while remaining vigilant for corvid 19
we are also closely monitoring the
monkey pox situation in canada and
internationally
as of august 19th a total of
168 confirmed cases of monkey pox
including 30 hospitalizations have been
reported nationally
with new brunswick reporting its first
confirmed case this week
nationally there has been a slowing
trend in the increase in new cases
reported
in recent weeks
over 99 of reported cases are male and
the median age was 36 years
among cases
confirmed cases for whom additional
information is available the majority
reported intimate sexual contact with
other men
the public health agency of canada has
distributed over 105
000 doses of immune vaccine to provinces
and territories with over 59 000 people
vaccinated with at least one dose as of
august 14th
at this time to lower the overall risk
of getting infected and spreading the
monkey pox virus
the public health agency of canada
recommends
practicing safer sex
having fewer sexual partners
particularly anonymous partners
even when they do not have symptoms can
also reduce your risk of getting
infected thank you thank you
thank you very much uh we will now go to
questions
we will now go to questions
if you have a question please use the
raise hand function raised hand function
it'll be one question one follow-up and
the first question goes to dylan
robertson from the winnipeg free press
uh hi dr tan uh some provinces have had
monkey pox cases for a while now but
other ones are just having their first
cases
we know the knowledge of this virus has
evolved over time so what advice could
you give to the government and to the
citizens of a province that have just
learned about their first case of monkey
pox do we have any sort of lessons
learned so far
yes hello dylan thank you for that
question and yes we have been learning
quite a bit more about this virus um
over the uh past several months
so uh as i've said in my opening remarks
uh certainly in the initial provinces
uh who've had cases
um it seems that there's a a
beginning to see a slowing trend um in
the trajectory of the epidemic curve
and so we are watching that very closely
we know
that
the vast majority
99
of reported cases
are males
who are
around the age of 36 as a median
so and the majority report intimate
sexual contact with other men so that
is
it's very important to support
community organizations
and people who have to trust and work
with
this
group because they are at the highest
risk of infection right now
and we have been distributing vaccines
to all provinces and territories
so
there is a consensus amongst the chief
medical officers that we should be
providing
a targeted approach to vaccinations at
the moment
to
groups at the highest risk of
exposure
so
um i think i will encourage
the sharing of this information
widely within jurisdictions i haven't
had any cases
so that people can take the necessary
precautions
and of course we
know
that by reducing
the
number of contacts
including sexual contacts anonymous
contacts intimate contacts in general
you can reduce your risk so
i think given that those facts um i
think we can um
make sure that
the cases don't increase rapidly in the
other jurisdictions
thank you and uh also for dr tam i'm
just wondering if you have any modeling
that might suggest how many undiagnosed
cases of monkey pox are circulating or
perhaps the national are not and if you
don't have these if you could just
clarify whether this might be coming at
a later briefing or if this is not the
amount of detail that faq is tabulating
right now
yes we don't have all
sufficient data to do forecasting for
example but we have been looking at
different scenarios using different r
naughts for example
and what we found was if we had
uncontrolled spread
our trajectory would be worse than where
we are now
and if we're following all those
different curves
we are seeing that in
quebec
and
also in ontario they're beginning to be
some slowing down
off of the trajectory which is good news
um but we need to keep going
and
um so so i think that's where we're at
right now um
so it's based on looking at those
scenarios
and i think internationally um
what we're finding is that of course the
risk
is high amongst um
the group of
gay bisexual men with sex with men in
terms of acquisition
and
um and transmission
but the r
uh rating is very
very different outside of this group so
and i think the estimates
are still above one but somewhere
between one and two
thank you next question goes to new
jerseys uh from uh canadian press
hi yeah my first question is about
today's announcement uh about boosters
for five to eleven-year-olds um your
language you say that for those who are
at high risk uh
should get the booster whereas you say
for all other children that they may get
a booster can you talk a little bit of
distinction in that kind of language and
and why
yes and this is language that nasty
often uses
and they can change over time with the
gathering of more information as well
so of course children with underlying
medical conditions at the highest risk
of severe outcomes
and if you're looking at the back the
benefit risk analysis
nasty based on current information in
the case that they should be offered
they are the highest risk of severe
outcomes
and for all other children
the risk of severe comes agen generally
rare
but i i'm a pediatrician i like to
remind parents that severe medical
conditions in this age group should be
rare
but this is preventable if you get
vaccinated so
so i think giving people the choice and
providing parents and kids with
information about the
effectiveness of vaccine and the
importance of the booster can help them
make this choice
thank you and my second question is
about um what we're hearing about a
potential vibrant vaccine and its
potential rollout in the fall for
parents who are people sorry for just
people who are watching this
should do you recommend that they
hold off on getting a booster until that
rolls out or should they get a booster
now what are your recommendations um
especially in the context of whether the
bivillion vaccine would be more
effective against new variants
so
that's a very topical question i think
and
first of all i know that our regulatory
colleagues in health canada are working
very fast at reviewing the submissions
from moderna and from fisa bayern tech
on the bivalent boosted doses meaning by
by veining we mean the original strain
as well as the ba1 strain that's the
information being submitted at this
point and
i know work is going on as fast as
possible
and we also have secure sufficient
supply of the bivalent formulation
should the regulatory authorities
um go on to authorize the vaccines
and i think that um
individuals should know that when we
look at the vaccine effectiveness of
that boosted dose in the age of omicron
it does restore your protection um
and
uh particularly against severe outcomes
so so even though the ancestral strain
um doesn't can well the current strain
doesn't only con contains the ancestral
strain
it's still
able to boost
what we're looking at is whether the
bivalent vaccine would have an added
benefit
and so that is currently being reviewed
i think it depends on your own set of
circumstances
and the epidemiologic situation
those who
prefer to wait for the availability of
the bivalent doses should also consider
their risk factors for exposure and the
potential for severe outcomes
because it's actually really important
not to
miss the chance
of getting your booster if it's been six
months since your last infection or last
vaccination
because if you waited too long the wave
could be starting and
you you then don't derive as much
benefit
but but that's what i would suggest to
look at your own set of circumstances
thank you uh the next question goes to
karen mckinley from the brandon sun
good morning everyone thank you for
taking the time just just on that for uh
boosters and covet 19 you said that
uh data showing uh
most jurisdictions in this country are
seem to be past uh the summer wave peak
uh that being said um considering uh the
aggressive vaccine campaigns we've had
over the last two years and going into
the fall which traditionally we've seen
has been meant more infections in
another way do you
do you have any kind of concerns or
predictions for
uh if there's going to be another wave
and what it may look like
yes so the summer months
tend to be the months where transmission
of respiratory viruses comes down but
even in the summer month we got this ba
5 wave
and the impact of the ba 5 wave is not
inconsequential
and has
like in the other waves um resulted in
quite a large number of hospitalizations
and indeed tragically deaths
particularly in the elderly
when we come to the fall
it is very likely that the transmission
would increase
as people go inside
and we want people to get back to normal
lives and be able to go to school go to
colleges get back to work
so under those circumstances we really
do need to layer on the protections is
is possible um although you know we
don't know yet it's possible that you
would get a bigger wave in the fall
compared to the summer and
but we definitely have to plan for it
even though we can't absolutely uh
project it at this time it's just that's
how respiratory viruses uh uh behave in
general so so i think we should plan
ahead for a bigger four wave
and therefore the province and
territories to get working with the
federal government uh you're going to
see a
rapid escalation of campaigns ahead of
the fall
so that people are supported in getting
access to the boosted doses as well as
being provided the information as to why
it's important
okay thank you for that and just the
follow-up leads into that because
manitoba has announced a while ago they
were
holding off on their
full vaccine campaign
and for boosters until
uh the bi-valence becomes available um
disappointing uh your thoughts on that
and also again i know you've said that
you're looking into the bivalent but is
does this mean that maybe it might be a
better option and people should perhaps
consider it over a traditional booster
yes and i think i i've mentioned also
depends on your risk factors and the
epidemiology in the local jurisdiction
but you know for the 80 plus age group
and this is what quebec is doing for
example
is um all the long-term care facilities
that if it's been over six months or
five to six months they're thinking well
we can't wait because
um you know the full uh escalation could
be upon us
and this is the group that can't really
wait um
but for other groups uh first of all if
you haven't actually got your primary
dose that this will be an important time
um
but for the younger age groups
depending on your uh risk factors
um you
you know you could consider waiting for
the bivalent dose
which is to come we don't know the exact
incremental benefits but we do know that
um
you know omicron is a very different
looking
virus
with a spike protein that's very
different and the new vaccine will
contain
um
that particular variant so
so i think um as i said you know if
you're gonna wait think about your risk
factors of and your potential exposure
wherever you're heading indoors
and um you know take that um
you know decision accordingly but i
think as i said the provinces will
provide more information i think in the
days
to come because of course we're now in
the middle of august
thank
and you mentioned children who are not
[Music]
that's not facing really high risk
because many
many children have had covenant already
so for this population would it be
better to wait for the new vaccine
for the question
in question
yes
every child
is
is
factor so it's about considering all
factors for the child in question of the
children
across the country
within those
risk of severe outcomes isn't very high
if it happens a pulmonary embolism or
something else which is very rare but if
it happens for a child and this is
something that's avoidable
well in that case
that might be grounds for going
for the currently available booster
doses but it is an important question
if you choose to wait you never know
what will happen with the next wave or
in the fall or in winter i see uh on a
tampon
yeah so i think
is
we were talking about up-to-date
vaccination every nine months but you're
referring to a period of six months
following the last dose i think
it's five months
so what is up-to-date vaccination
is it nine months six months five months
okay can we clarify that a bit more
thank you the
perspective okay
a technical perspective adopted by
public health
are there any other questions
going once going twice
ah karen
second karen mckinley from brandon son
again more of a scientific question
um just taking a look at how
these outbreaks and all these viruses
and diseases have been coming out
of course with monkey pox uh it's
adjacent to smallpox and i'm just
looking here on
on my news feed and i see uh first case
of polio in a decade has emerged in the
united states
um so just thinking
going forward are we going to have to
rethink
um how we consider uh certain diseases
and viruses quote unquote eradicated or
no longer a public uh threat if they
keep popping up or mutating
that's that is quite a big question so
i'll just answer the question uh about
re-emerging uh vaccine-preventable
diseases the vaccines against polio are
very effective
the issue is under immunisation
so i think for for
illnesses like measles like polio
um the key is to get up to date with
your vaccination
um i think
the the vaccine coverage is generally
quite high for polio in canada
but i don't know what happened during
the pandemic i hope people are getting
caught up before school and before
before
you know travel et cetera
but that's really important so that's
that group of of
already vaccine preventable diseases
for emerging infectious disease
some of here some of which and many of
which come from from animal to human
transmission
we expect those might actually increase
given climate change and other
factors and global travel
so we do need to prepare and re do
research and not ignore them
monkey parks as we know has been
knocking
on outdoors for
quite some time and has now found a way
of getting into the human population
fortunately vaccines have been
researched
and we have some of that
maybe not enough for the global needs
but at least all the research have been
done prior
so what you need to do i think and there
are many global um collaboration
collaborations that need more support i
think to look at the risk there are the
sort of list of viruses
that might become the next pandemic
virus
and we need to think longer term and be
able to support bioma manufacturing
infrastructures that can help us
be prepared
uh it may not happen for a number of
years but one day it would arrive at our
doorsteps and you don't want to be in
the same position again
so i think um
thinking that longer term
not ignoring signals when they keep
knocking on our doors
is is really important
and you know we've learned a number of
lessons
in public health i'm always worried that
yes we've learned these lessons a few
years later this boom and bust
phenomenon occurs where there's lots of
attention paid to these
infectious diseases now
and then people forget it in the
intervening years and then they're
surprised that we actually might get
another pandemic or another significant
outbreak
in in our near future
thank you for that
karen do you have a follow-up
uh no that was it for me thank you um
thanks for that sir
okay are there any other questions
are there any other questions
one going once going twice
ah there's dylan
okay
i always have questions thanks so much
um i just wanted to know how you're
feeling dr tan about the rollout of the
monkey pox vaccine i realize your job is
not to punch down on provinces but just
if you're seeing things that are
encouraging you
if you think there's room for
maneuvering to improve the rollout of
these monkey pulse vaccines
thank you for the question and i think
we've had some really great uh
collaboration with the province
territories but even more importantly
collaboration from the community groups
so i think in general
the knowledge is getting out but we can
always do more and that's why
i think the federal government for
example is supporting community groups
you've heard some other funding
announcements because we think that's
going to be one of the most effective
things of course it's great for chief
medical officers and provincial
government officials and our teams to
promote vaccination but i think it's
always
um really effective if we can engage the
community so so i think that can always
um you know improve all the time i learn
about how to communicate on infectious
diseases and vaccinations every day and
i learned mainly from the people with
the lived and they've lived in living
experience and so that's been really
helpful
um i do think that there's
a fair enthusiasm to get the vaccine
so that's a that's good and
the key question has been you know from
the province to us is whether we would
have enough vaccine for pre-exposure
prophylaxis for this high-risk group and
we we do have the supplies
but we need to be good stewards of that
supply so
we're monitoring that very closely
and
continuing to do the science around the
timing and the interval
for a subsequent dose
and also as i said last week looking
into those sparing strategies such as
the the one that the us is doing with
the fraction
fractional dosing so all of those are at
play but um i think as usual is is not a
singular thing but it's a collaborative
approach to
getting uh the chains of transmission
disrupted
thank you and just in a similar vein i
just wanted to get your thoughts on
where we're at in canada with paige
sickly when it comes to covet and monkey
pox and everything else because you know
in your annual reports you've talked
about how sick leave and these sort of
policy interventions can help people
actually quarantine when they need to
um you know i don't suspect that you're
getting labor data all the time but i
guess i'm just wondering if this is
still
a live conversation with the medical
officers of health or if we've sort of
moved on from this just given provinces
peeling back these sorts of programs
um i i think it is still a live
discussion particularly we're hearing
from community groups
um who are saying that you know some
some people really do need to be
supported more
to isolate if they have
to if they have uh monkey parks
and so i do think is a as a broader
policy
um conversation and decision
not just for the federal government's
really all levels of government and how
we support people
um
in in in their
in their need to isolate not just to get
well
but also to protect transmission and so
um i know that the federal government
continues to support save voluntary
isolation sites for covet 19.
we um still ha you know i i was very
happy to see policies social policies
um come into play when covet 19 occurred
so i think we need to be able to
leverage
the
success and lessons learned
it's very difficult to ask people to
follow public health measures sometimes
particularly those in equity deserving
groups
and
that is actually one of the components
of success i think in future pandemic
response as well
thank you uh
are there any other questions
thank you very much for being here to
answer our questions
this press conference